les images les plus commentées c'est
justement Emmanuel Macron aux côtés de
Mbappé sur le terrain à l'issue du match
le président plus que collé à
l'attaquant ce qui fait dire à un
médecin sur Twitter on aurait aimé que
Emmanuel Macron vienne nous soutenir
comme ça aux urgences vous imaginez
François Mitterrand avec Michel Platini
assez vie je crois qu'on a basculé en
fait on est maintenant il y a plus que
l'image il y a plus rien d'autre il y a
plus rien d'autre la presse
internationale se demande comment il a
pu se retrouver sur le terrain à
consoler Mbappe les internautes eux
soulignent un dribble impassible du
joueur pour ne pas rentrer dans un jeu
récupérateur et compare le président à
un gros lourd en boîte de nuit
qui sont très jeunes
qui vont en faire beaucoup d'autres plus
que moi comme président avant de
conclure en tout cas moi je suis fier de
vous vive la république et vive la
France
vous êtes venus avec un ami à vous qui
s'appelle Malik bonjour Malik bonjour On
dirait Olivier Giroud avec 10 ans de
moins franchement on voulait jamais dit
c'est la première fois
Brigitte Macron la femme du président de
la République qui était là elle aussi au
pied de l'avion dame de mauvaise
compagnie
une légère Emmanuel Macron qui s'est
sans doute laissé emporter par trop
d'émotions en twitant à 19h05 ce message
avec une superbe faute d'orthographe
message effacé et repose 8 minutes plus
tard le verbe avoir a bien retrouvé son
thé
merci à vous merci Estelle et ceux qui
vont peut-être arrêter le maillot après
ce match
[Musique]
stop je suis fier de vous merci à celles
et ceux qui voient
et là ça contretemps parce qu'on a perdu
est-ce que ce match nous dit aussi c'est
qu'il y a jamais de scénario avec écrit
d'avance que c'est toujours possible et
donc on est une grande nation de foot on
est aussi une grande nation tout court
escroc et en gardant tout le blé
déjà rien qu'à ça on voyait le caractère
malheureusement totalement grotesque de
cette espèce d'obsession de de son image
et de sa communication qui est terrible
qui tient presque de la pathologie à ce
stade c'est hallucinant d'être à ce
point obsédé par l'image qu'on renvoie
la comme le truc merci la tête à ce
point d'un narcissique c'est terrible
mais l'équipe de France nous a régalé
disent les téléspectateurs
c'est une belle soirée il y a rien à
regretter allez sourions la vie est
belle
Mont Blanc
un fan de foot que ça te détestation de
Macron ta détestation de Macron est
égale à cette barbares
je vous avoue que j'avais une vraie
angoisse avec cette expression le 31 va
s'embrasser sous le gui parce que j'ai
un voisin chez mes parents qui
s'appelait Guy et je me disais je vois
mal comment on va se faire la bise entre
les jambes d'osga et j'avais pas envie
d'y aller en plus on a tellement chaud
qu'on ait pu habituer à faire ça pour
vous dire regardez cette année on a eu
en fait des valeurs de mon été 5 de
grandes sous des valeurs de saison il
faut savoir que cette année en 2022 on a
seulement été huit fois 5 degrés en
dessous des valeurs de saison mais 40
fois 5 degrés au-dessus des valeurs de
saison donc ça veut dire que quoi qu'il
se passe maintenant en décembre on est
sûr que cette année 2022 sera la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée nous sommes
ravis d'accueillir un nouveau membre de
notre service je lui laisse la parole
[Musique]
il fera froid partout avec lui degrés et
un petit vent glacial heureusement que
ce n'est pas sérieux demain
donc autant vous dire que il va faire
chaud que le Père Noël va pas glisser va
pas déraper il risque de se noyer en
revanche alors j'aimerais beaucoup
qu'avec mes copains tu nous transformes
en dessin animé
j'en reviens pas c'est génial incroyable
tous les détails ouais cette moto
n'appartient pas au jeune homme il l'a
emprunté à son frère qui visiblement
n'était pas au courant ou tu prends ma
moto espèce de
cul eh monsieur